you can't be that one right you can't be
the one to pay for the meal and because
you're dating down
you remember this video we covered this
a while back I think it's so interesting
I'm curious if you think this is one of
our earlier videos
we already covered it we already covered
it but I'm curious if you feel like
something changed so this one's a
classic if you guys uh I haven't seen
this one it's good fighting love is not
that easy right and it's especially hard
in this economy and guess what many
women say they are finding it very hard
to find a man who makes as much as they
do a study by Cornell University found
that the country's declining marriage
rate is due to the lack of financially
eligible bachelors women are actually
outpacing men with education and this is
changing the age-old mentality that men
are the Breadwinners it turned in turn
the gig or small gigs economy and lack
of good jobs out there have left the
ladies single and disgruntled and
researchers say they are seeing a trend
of women dating down which means
video yeah this is one of our first
videos that went viral yes and I want to
rewatch it just with a different lens
years later just curious to see if
anything that you think about it changes
or if you have a deeper appreciation for
what happens let's go but guys
women don't want to date down
they want to date up which means they
want you to date down
but black dude is my dude
I mean who I say all that Jesus I
disgruntled this is just the reality of
it so women you know we're more educated
now and I think that we're furthering
our education so with that being said
we're going to hold off on the baby
making we're going to hold off until we
get that great job really career driven
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with hoping that there's someone either
on your level or higher than you so okay
all right so before right it was okay
when the man made more money to be the
one to buy everything to do you know
treat you and all this other kind of
stuff and now that you make more money
you can't be that one right you can't be
the one to pay for the meal and because
you're dating down damn I hate
oh
you're getting down yeah what is that
about it wasn't called dating down right
yeah he's about to
look at the woman's reaction when he's
like I don't like that I don't like that
no you don't like you don't like that
but that's that's what it is you wanted
all the hey hey you know what they say
lies are sweet but the truth that [ __ ]
is bitter it comes from the back door
pow pause
yeah you had to say that you said it
back on like [ __ ] that's gay she was
not expecting it it came through her
back door
Raw
raw no Vaseline the way he came in
he raises a good point yeah I think now
that Society has changed the women are
killing it women are outpacing men when
it comes to education in some cities and
women are even out earning men uh you're
seeing all these like societal ships but
it's hard to let go of some of those old
standards so it's interesting hearing
the term dating down now because in the
past we never really kind of saw it that
way so interesting that women kind of
still hold on to that term because it
shows you that women value men obviously
for their financial ability or their
education level whereas men never really
saw it that way and so there's no idea
of dating down back then and so it just
speaks to how Society understands what
women are looking for generally when it
comes to these partners and that's
reinforced by stats feeling though that
some of the issue here is that it may be
the psyche of the men that when they
make less they are insecure and it can
support us about the women complaining
about the fact that oh now I gotta get
in again so are these women expecting
the men to cover everything they want
those Breadwinners so they that's what
it sounds like to me by this particular
study I have to date down now what is
that
you wanted to make more money look at
her face her face is amazing
she's like yeah no women are doing
better so we want better no you want to
do better you want there's a thing okay
women wanted to be equal as men okay
therefore you're gonna have to do
equality things you understand hmm
you want to do it quote the future is
female then pay the bills
I'll stay home with the kids how about
that work the job no you don't get a
maternity leave I get a paternity leave
you go that's what you wanted you the
future now
oh no that's you that's you no I'll go
be a secretary you go build this city
you're going to sewers and work that job
no that's you that's what you want you
want equality equality is going to come
in all aspects the good and the not so
good true
so you want that you get that get it
you wanted to make more money you make
more money if if there is a
responsibility with making more money
first of all I don't believe in any of
it but if there's a responsibility that
comes with making more money accept it
you wanted to make more money
[Music]
you wanted to make more money
right you know are you gonna find many
men out there that makes as much as you
do and my point is so now you're going
to because we hear so much about women
that are like oh there's nobody out
there there's no one out there I can't
find love I'm getting too old now you're
going to sacrifice the fact that you
could find that love because the man's
not making that much money and you're
going to dig down they're wrapping us I
have a feeling this is going to be our
morning Rush actually
left to say all right time now 5 11.
oh you petty ass you petty ass feeling
this is going to be our morning Rush
actually by myself left to say all right
time now 5 11. let's let's get to what's
ahead all right
buy a dog and die alone
[Music]
that's what he's gonna say and I'm not
even mad enough and and that's the thing
and that's the thing it hadn't it it
hasn't changed because when we when we
first made that video you asked me if
there's something that I changed no it
hasn't changed uh well actually yeah it
just went worse because back then in
that video they're talking about women
that are earning more
one they don't want a day down true now
women don't even want to date down they
just expect up
I'm just gonna sit here not do nothing
in this place of in this era of equality
I'm just gonna sit here not do nothing I
made the decision you get your money out
of my body my choices your money my
choices no yeah 400k to whatever to
whatever the infinity and beyond calm
the [ __ ] down Buzz Lightyear that's not
what it is okay it got worse it actually
got worse because in that vid yeah in
that video people are talking about I
make a lot of money I want someone that
makes that matches or do now it has
gotten worse now you know I think the
idea that you're dating down because
someone makes less than you it's kind of
weird because people can contribute to
relationships in ways other than just
financially mean preach do not have the
same roles in this partnership right but
we both contribute to it in ways that
are very very meaningful and as a result
we value what the other person brings I
wouldn't say I'm working down or
whatever because someone doesn't have a
specific skill set that I have the same
one I don't have his skill set in
certain areas now how women are far out
pacing when it comes to education men
are dropping out like crazy going into
trades going into different jobs and so
they're abandoning school and large
drugs I don't think it's a good thing I
just think it's reality yeah and women
are taking their place and I think it's
great in a way because you're seeing
that women excel in academic sense in a
lot of um in a lot of areas but what
heads off happening is like dating
changes you know what I'm saying then
changes and so since things change you
gotta change with the times you get me
all right you gotta change with the
times listen horses that's the pass out
here we riding cars I get it cars we
like horses you like going whatever it
is that shit's over
roll that clip back and see her posture
change just like because you went in
like a she went from this so my [ __ ]
We're not gonna talk about her booty
hole okay let's move on so all this to
say has my opinion changed on that video
no I have a deeper appreciation for it I
thought it still just as enjoyable it's
a good discussion it's a good
disagreement it's even better I know
sometimes morning TV is not so bad it's
even better these guys they're
[Music]
she's a gorgeous woman she's a great
looking she got a good job she that this
this woman looks good and I'm like if
you destroy like there's no way she
doesn't have
dozens hundreds of Bachelors prospects
who are there's no way lining up there's
no way GM's flaming so that means boom
Dev standards gotta be crazy bro
straight up that or you know I mean the
coochie's infected but I don't want to
make the assumptions
we're not doing that I mean we're not
I'm doing that so he's one or the other
the standards are here
or something wrong or the coochie
Staters are here you get what I'm saying
one or the other but at the end of the
day it is what it is now yeah so so you
know I'm hoping I'm praying for y'all
you know what I'm saying I want y'all to
find yourself and then that [ __ ] sounds
really there's a lot of women out there
saying that [ __ ] that [ __ ] really sounds
like a good idea
I'm gonna die alone yo
loneliness is very lonely but I just
said sounds very stupid but loneliness
you think it's a fade it's when it's
lonely it's very lonely it's lonely as
[ __ ] and some boy you wish you had
somebody cook and you're gonna go out or
put a pillow between your legs and go to
sleep because you want girl stop